l'effervescence et la vitalité du
Quartier des spectacles de Montréal
cache une réalité beaucoup plus sombre
dans les rues voisines
l'itinérance est en croissance dans la
métropole à cause de la crise du
logement et la toxicomanie explose aussi
depuis la pandémie avoir su que ça ça
aurait déménager à côté de chez moi
je
Andre sur la rue charlotte au coin de la
rue Berger les habitants des immeubles à
condo surnomme l'endroit l'allée du CRAC
[Musique]
regardez tellement pisser partout que le
tout est en train de rouiller les
résidents des condos de la rue Charlotte
se plaignent que les toxicomanes par
effraction de leurs immeubles pour se
droguer ou pour dormir à l'intérieur les
dégâts sont estimés à plusieurs dizaines
de milliers de dollars les branches
dehors
il vient de s'injecter des drogues on
trouve des singes juste ici des condons
à peu près tout plusieurs résidents
montrent du doigt le centre d'injection
supervisé à proximité cactus Montréal
accueille chaque jour plus de 200
toxicomanes qui viennent consommer des
drogues dures à l'intérieur en sécurité
mais l'organisme ne suffit plus à la
demande croissante alors ça déborde à
l'extérieur le manque d'espace pour ces
gens-là fait en sorte que ces gens-là
ils vont aller où ils vont aller dans
leurs entrées d'immeuble ils vont
essayer de rentrer dans les cours
ils ont pas de toilette ils ont besoin
de déféquer ils vont pas déféquer dans
un endroit vu tous donc ils vont aller
dans un endroit caché et ça c'est des
entrés d'immeubles cactus manque aussi
de ressources et d'infirmières ce qu'il
a forcé à réduire ses heures d'ouverture
et sa capacité d'accueil tout ça
survient alors que le nombre de surdoses
dans les centres d'injection supervisés
de Montréal est passé de 77 l'année
d'avant la pandémie à 351 l'année
dernière une augmentation de
450%. il y a un problème actuellement
dans le centre-ville de Montréal il y a
une crise humaine qui se déroule sous
nos yeux et je pense que le désarroi de
mes concitoyens le sentiment
d'insécurité de mes concitoyens
concitoyens d'ailleurs qui vivent en
condo qui vivent dans la rue il y a un
sentiment d'insécurité énorme et je
pense que l'air est à vraiment relevé
les manches et travailler ensemble tout
le monde puis moi je comprends tout à
fait lors des armoires c'est sûr que eux
ils sont arrivés pour vivre la vie du
centre-ville à proximité de de travail
le Quartier des spectacles la vie
urbaine etc et en fait ils ont retrouvé
de la vie urbaine mais c'est pas la vie
urbaine à laquelle il s'attendait les
résidents ont envoyé plusieurs appels à
l'aide aux autorités mais il se sentent
abandonnés ils écrivent dans un courriel
nous ne comprenons pas ce qu'attend la
ville pour venir intervenir la police ne
se déplace plus ou avec des délais
dépassant l'entendement la Ville de
Montréal et les policiers nous assurent
être mobilisés pour la sécurité des
résidents la santé publique de Montréal
se dit tout de même extrêmement
préoccupé par la situation actuelle dans
le centre-ville ici Thomas Gerber
Radio-Canada Montréal
c'est le principe la consommation a
augmenté pas seulement chez les gens de
la rue on l'a vu dans les domiciles les
familles ça boit plus ça fume plus ça
consomme plus le facteur qu'on a vu
arriver avec la pandémie c'est la
détérure la détérioration de la qualité
des substances qui circulent sur la rue
en ce moment c'est catastrophique on
sait qu'avec la pandémie entre autres
l'accès à certaines drogues comme
l'héroïne la cocaïne toujours été très
difficile donc les trafiquants quand ils
reçoivent la drogue qui l'ont payé deux
trois fois plus cher mais ils doivent la
couper avec des ingrédients qui sont
souvent plus toxiques puis qui coulent
souvent plus de problèmes de santé
mentale comme des psychoses la paranoïa
de l'anxiété donc l'autre point je pense
majeur c'est non pas le manque d'espace
pour loger ces gens-là c'est le manque
d'accès à ces espaces je m'explique
manque pas de logement mais en fait
c'est juste qu'ils sont pas capables
mais en fait regardez premier exemple je
vous donnerai des tours à bureau au
centre-ville en ce moment-là
que 20% des bureaux sont inoccupés je
dis pas qu'il faut mettre des
toxicomanes avec des gens d'affaires
dans le même bureau mais il y en a des
espaces je donne un autre exemple
l'Hôpital Royal Victoria qui est fermé
depuis quelques années ce que des gens
qu'on pourrait héberger là il y a des
chambres aménagées donc c'est vraiment
le manque d'accès à ces endroits là je
pense que une pénurie de main d'oeuvre
donc si on avait accès à ces endroits là
il y a une pénurie d'infirmière aussi
c'est un peu puisque la clinique le
centre d'injonctions
mais vous savez avant madame prince
avait beaucoup de maisons de chambre je
sais pas si vous avez déjà entendu
l'expression mais on chante donc c'était
des gros building où les gens avaient
une chambre avec accès à de l'eau à une
cuisine pour quelques centaines de
dollars on en a plus de ça il y en a
pratiquement plus des maisons sont été
transformées en condominum auquel même
des familles n'ont pas accès par manque
de salaire fait imaginer des gens de la
rue sont obligés de consommer dans la
rue surtout avec des drogues d'une
qualité médiocre qui se retrouve prise
avec des problèmes de douleur chronique
ou de santé mentale moi j'ai pas la
solution
ultime à tout ça mais je peux selon moi
dire que c'était prévisible
malheureusement on voit que les
autorités aussi se relancent la balle
parce que quand on demande à la Ville de
Montréal si elle intervient elle dit bah
oui on a ajouté par exemple des
escouades pour amasser les seringues
souillées on fait de l'intervention on
fait de la sensibilisation le
gouvernement du Québec dit bon on a
ajouté du financement les policiers
affirment faire plus de patrouille mais
à la fin c'est quand même les résidents
qui se retrouvent avec le problème qui
sont capables de régler tout à fait on a
un manque de ressources dans tous les
domaines tout le monde le sait mais je
pense que tous ces gens-là qui sont dans
la rue sont des êtres humains d'abord
avant tout je pense pas que personne qui
a l'âge de 5-6 ans rêvait de devenir
itinérant ou toxicoman dans la rue et je
pense que on a vraiment besoin de se
parler au lieu de se lancer la balle
parce que là oui il y a des fonds qui
sont allés où les fonds donc par le
gouvernement ouais ce sont allés les
sites d'injection supervisées je pense
que c'est une bonne chose mais là il y a
des employés qui commencent à avoir peur
et regarder le nombre de surdos je vais
exploser de 2019 à 2023 on parle de
450% d'augmentation les surdoses à
l'intérieur de ces centres oui ça c'est
seulement les surdoses dans les centres
d'injections on parle pas des sources
dans la rue ou les appartements on ne le
sait pas donc je pense que quel
peut-être une notion là on est en train
presque de voir naître dans le temps les
Side à Montréal c'est en train de voir
seulement toujours est-ce que ça va
finir par arriver chez on dirait que ça
commence en tout cas du moins c'est
installé il y a vous savez qu'en
Colombie Britannique un projet pilote
que tes membranles quelques mois de sous
on doit décriminaliser la possession
simple de deux grammes et demi de toute
substance donc c'est quand on dit que
les policiers sont débordés
pour arrêter quelqu'un pour un grand et
demi de cocaïne dans les poches là je
pense que les policiers ont d'autres
choses à faire que ça les policiers
devraient toujours avoir de la loxone
avec eux ce qui est malheureusement pas
toujours le cas encore aujourd'hui les
ambulanciers devant la voir la
décrivalisation de la possession simple
l'analyse de substances donc on sait
qu'on a déjà trois quatre sites à
Montréal nous on en fait avec projet
caméléon dans les festivals l'analyse de
substance peut pas peut-être pas
prévenir l'itinérance mais peut prévenir
des surdoses ou des mauvaises réactions
à une drogue de mauvaise qualité tu sais
si quelqu'un va faire analyser sa coque
puis finalement sa cocaïne puis
finalement on trouve des selles de bain
dedans des catinoles c'est extrêmement à
risque de psychose mais ça se peut que
la personne décide de ne pas le
consommer les gens sont pas stupides les
toxiquement c'est des gens souffrant
d'abord et avant tout qui essaye de
calmer leur souffrance avec la
consommation puis sachez que 50% des
personnes dépendantes aux hôpitaux
souffrent de douleurs chroniques
donc la douleur il y a pas un humain qui
est masochiste qui veut tolérer de la
douleur fait qu'on fait ce qu'on peut
pour se soulager et il y a au moins 50%
des toxicomanes qui souffrent d'une
pathologie psychiatrique primaire comme
la bipolarité des troubles sur le TDAH
qu'est-ce qu'ils offre ni donc il faut
traiter les problèmes à la base c'est
correct de donner des singes c'est
correct d'avoir des sites d'injection
supervisées c'est correct de faire
d'analyse de substance mais je pense
qu'il faut traiter la souffrance à la
base et oui on manque de soldats on
manque de personnel partout dans le
milieu vous le savez mais je pense c'est
une personne s'approche de vous une
demande de la monnaie on en a même plus
de monnaie sur nous donner un bout de
nourriture ou quelque chose un morceau
de vêtement ou n'importe quoi mais je
comprends que les gens agressifs à des
gens qui font peur
mais n'oublions pas qu'à la base tous
des êtres humains comme nous puis je
pense que l'exemple du directeur de
cactus tantôt qui parlait des besoins
d'aller à la selle si je veux aussi tu
as besoin de base soit d'aller aux
toilettes il y en a même pas fait que on
devrait ouvrir peut-être d'autres sens
moi je pense qu'on devrait ouvrir des
maisons de chambre ça c'est sûr que les
maisons de chambre n'ont pas
nécessairement besoin d'infirmière c'est
des gens qui sont quand même autonomes
qui payent leur chance qui ont accès à
une cuisine commune puis à une toilette
ou de l'eau mais je veux dire regardez
le prix des logements en ce moment là
c'est complètement aberrant même pour
les gens qui travaillent imaginez quand
on est dans la rue fait que je n'ai pas
de solution
ultime j'ai des pistes de solution mais
comme je voudrais répète moi je vous dis
que la situation était prévisible avec
la pandémie ça va prendre vraiment une
mobilisation exactement c'est vraiment
et que tout le monde se parle au lieu de
se lancer la balle merci beaucoup
bonne soirée merci